frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen es fällt
einigermaßen schwer nach dieser
Gedenkstunde heute morgen jetzt ganz
einfach zur Tagesordnung
überzugehen vielleicht darf ich damit
beginnen dass ich Ihnen Frau Präsidentin
aber auch unseren beiden Gästen die
heute morgen hier gesprochen haben Eva
cepesi und Marcel Reif noch einmal sehr
ich Dank sage für die bewegenden Worte
die sie gesprochen
haben und ich möchte ein weiteres Wort
des Dankes hinzufügen am Montag der
letzten Woche hat der französische
Staatspräsident Emmanuel macron von
dieser Stelle aus und zu Ehren unseres
verstorbenen Kollegen Wolfgang schäble
eine ich finde das darf man auch heute
noch einmal sagen eine wirklich große
Rede gehalten
Emmanuel macron hat uns Deutschen erneut
die Hand sehr weit ausgestreckt er hat
uns in seiner Rede geradezu
aufgefordert zusammen mit seinem Land
zusammen mit Frankreich
Führungsverantwortung in und für
Europa zu übernehmen und ein Blick auf
die aktuelle Lage in der Welt ein Blick
auf die Krisen und die Kriege mit denen
wir nun auch in das Jahr 2024
hineingehen zeigt uns Deutschland sollte
ja Deutschland muss diese ausgestreckte
Hand des französischen Staatspräsidenten
jetzt
ergreifen
Deutschland muss gemeinsam mit
Frankreich neue Initiativen erarbeiten
um die Handlungsfähigkeit Europas unter
Beweis zu stellen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich möchte uns daran erinnern
dass die letzte große deutsche
Initiative für Europa aus dem Jahre
1989 stammt also heute schon mehr als 35
Jahre alt ist im Zuge der wiedererein
unseres Landes legte der damalige
Außenminister Hans Diedrich Genscher
abgestimmt mit Frankreich ein
währungspolitisches Memorandum vor aus
dem dann gut 10 Jahre später die
Währungsunion wurde die letzte große
industriepolitische Initiative für
Europa die aus Deutschland kam liegt
mittlerweile fast 60 Jahre zurück es war
im Jahr
1965 die Gründung der
Arbeitsgemeinschaft Airbus so hieß sie d
s zwischen Deutschland aus Frank und
Frankreich aus der dann wie wir alle
wissen der größte europäische Luft und
raumfahrtkonzern wurde ich nenne diese
Beispiel weil sie zeigen die Zeit ist
mehr als reif für Vorschläge in
Licher Dimension und mit vergleichbarer
Tragweite Vorschläge die vor allem von
Deutschland und Frankreich auf den Weg
gebracht werden
müssen und erlauben Sie mir dass ich
hinzufüge
das wären auch Vorschläge die uns
Europäer
vorbereiten auf einen möglichen Wechsel
im Weißen Haus in Washington ich will
zwei sehr konkrete Beispiele nennen was
früher die Währungspolitik war muss
heute im Interesse Europas die Außen und
die Sicherheitspolitik sein Deutschland
und Frankreich müssen enger
zusammenarbeiten und auf dem Weg hin zu
einer gemeinsamen europäischen verte
igungspolitik so früh wie möglich andere
Mitgliedstaaten der Europäischen Union
mit einbeziehen nach dem
Regierungswechsel in Polen vor allem die
neue polnische Regierung diese
gemeinsame Verteidigungspolitik meine
Damen und Herren muss von Anfang an die
Rüstungspolitik die Beschaffung und die
militärische Unterstützung der Ukraine
beinhalten und was früher früher die
Luft und Raumfahrtindustrie war müssen
heute die Unternehmen der
digitalwirtschaft der Telekommunikation
und die Banken sein Deutschland und
Frankreich sollten so bald wie möglich
Verabredungen darüber treffen wie denn
in diesen und anderen Sektoren wirklich
europäische weltweit wettbewerbsfähige
Unternehmen entstehen
könnte dazu muss das europäische
Kartellrecht geändert werden denn der
sogenannte relevante Markt für diese
Unternehmen ist längst nicht mehr allein
Europa oder schon gar nicht der einzelne
Mitgliedstaat Staat sondern der globale
Markt auf dem europäische Unternehmen
wettbewerbsfähig sein müssen meine Damen
und Herren zu allen diesen strategischen
Fragen zu dieser strategischen
Neuausrichtung Europas sollte das Format
des Weimarer Dreiecks wiederbelebt
werden am besten mit einer sehr bald
ausgesprochenen Einladung der deutschen
Bundesregierung nach Weimar um von dort
aus den Weg hin zu einer gemeinsamen
europäischen außen und
Sicherheitspolitik und auch hin zu einer
gemeinsamen EUR Industriepolitik zu
beschreiten
Deutschland Deutschland sollte diese
Aufgabe aus einer Position der Stärke
und der Verantwortung zugleich
übernehmen voraussetzung dafür ist dass
Deutschland seine Wachstumsschwäche
überwindet diese Wachstumsschwäche meine
Damen und
Herren hat ganz überwiegend strturelle
Gründe und hängt zusammen mit
Standortbedingungen die in mehrfacher
Hinsicht unzureichend sind ich will es
auf einen ganz einfachen Nenner bringen
die Arbeitskosten in Deutschland sind zu
hoch die Bürokratielasten werden immer
drückender die Energieversorgung ist zu
einseitig auf Wind und Sonne
ausgerichtet und die Steuerlast der
Unternehmen ist im internationalen
Vergleich ebenfalls zu
hoch
Spielräume Spielräume in den
öffentlichen Haushalten lassen sich
erzielen wenn Sozialleistungen unseres
Landes auf die konzentriert werden die
sie wirklich brauchen wenn die
Lohnzusatzkosten wieder bei 40%
gedeckelt werden und wenn die gesamte
Last der Transformation hin zur
Klimaneutralität unserer Volkswirtschaft
nicht allein über Subventionen aus den
staatlichen Haushalten finanziert
wird ETW konkreter
machen wir sollten in Zukunft in der
Sozialpolitik wieder stärker
unterscheiden zwischen
beitragsfinanzierten
Lohnersatzleistungen und
steuerfinanzierten
Sozialleistungen Lohnersatzleistungen
für die die Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer Beiträge gezahlt haben
dienen der Überbrückung einer begrenzten
Zeit der Arbeitslosigkeit bei
gleichzeitigem Erhalt des
Lebensstandards steuerfinanzierte
Sozialleistungen dienen der Währung des
Existenzminimums und eines Minimums
einer sozialen Teilhabe und nur wenn
zwischen Arbeitseinkommen und
Sozialleistungen ein hinreichend großer
Abstand besteht wird die
Leistungsbereitschaft der
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer auch
hinreichend belohnt meine Damen und
Herren deshalb deshalb ist das System
Bürgergeld das genaue Gegenteil von dem
was wir jetzt brauchen um diese
Leistungsbereitschaft unser
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer
wieder zu
fördern und meine Damen und Herren
dieser Befund wird durch empirische
Erhebungen
bestätigt wenn die Sozialpolitik so
schreibt Renate Köcher in der letzten
Woche in ihrer monatlichen Erhebung wenn
diezial tik zu einer Annäherung von
unterstützungs und Erwerbseinkommen
führt verliert sie an Vertrauen und
Unterstützung und zwar besonders in der
Mittelschicht und in den schwächeren
sozialen Schichten meine Damen und
Herren gerade von der
Sozialdemokratischen Partei Deutschlands
sie waren sie waren einmal die Partei
der ArbeiterInnen und Arbeit der
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer sie
sind heute eine Partei der
subventionierten Arbeitslosigkeit
geworden und nicht mehr eine Partei der
Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer wir sehen in unserem Land
die gleichen Fehlsteuerungen in einer
Energie und Klimapolitik die vor allem
auf umfangreiche Förderprogramme und auf
staatliche Subventionen setzt der Weg
hin zu einer klimaneutralen
Volkswirtschaft und zu der dafür
benötigten Infrastruktur lässt sich
nicht allein über öffentliche Haushalte
beschreiten dieses
Land unser Land meine Damen und Herren
braucht mutige aber realistische Ziele
unser Land wird den Wettbewerb auf der
Welt nur gewinnen wenn wir aufhören alle
anderen zu belehren und immer wieder
einen Sonderweg zu
suchen wir
brauchen wir brauchen
Wirkungsmechanismen über den Preis wie
mit der Bepreisung des
schadstoffausschusses und wir brauchen
in erheblichem Umfang wir brauchen in
erheblichem Umfang privates Kapital für
den Ausbau der Infrastruktur
insbesondere des benötigten
Leitungsnetzes und meine Damen und
Herren das alles ob sie das nun wollen
oder nicht geht nicht ohne einen ja die
Zwischenrufe zeigen ja dass ich sie
genau an der Stelle erreiche wo Sie
einfach die größte Schwäche haben in
ihrer gesamten Argumentation
meine Damen und Herren das alles was ich
hier gerade beschreibe geht nicht ohne
einen tieferen und einen breiteren
europäischen Kapitalmarkt und auch dazu
wird Frankreich zusammen mit uns und
anderen ohne Zweifel bereit sein nun
werden sie und ich höre es an ihren
Zwischenrufen spätestens an dieser
Stelle fragen was diese Themen denn mit
ihrer Koalition und ihrem heute hier zur
Abstimmung gestellten Bundeshaushalt zu
tun haben ich will Ihnen die Antwort
geben gar nichts gar nichts sie haben
gar nichts damit zu tun wir sind wir
sind nämlich meine Damen und
Herren wir sind nämlich in allen
wesentlichen Fragen der außen und
Sicherheitspolitik der Wirtschafts und
Finanzpolitik der Arbeitsmarktpolitik
der innen und Rechtspolitik und nicht
zuletzt der Asyl und
Einwanderungspolitik vollkommen anderer
Meinung als sie und zwar nicht im Grund
nicht im Detail sondern im Grundsatz im
Grund
und das ist ganz
einfach das ist ganz einfach der Grund
dafür dass wir darauf verzichtet haben
in den Haushaltsberatungen irgendwelche
Änderungsanträge zu stellen ja meine
Damen und Herren wir wissen doch wie das
geht wir stellen die Anträge sie lehnen
alle Anträge ab Sie addieren die Summen
unser Anträge und halten uns dann hier
im Deutschen Bundestag im Plenum vor
hätten noch höhere Ausgaben
vorgeschlagen das ist doch genau der
Wirkungsmechanismus den wir von ihnen
immer wieder hören wenn sie so nicht
verstehen dann will ich es ihnen etwas
da Lopper sagen wenn sie nein meine
Damen und Herren wenn Sie die Jacke
unten falsch einknöpfen dann diskutieren
wir nicht mit ihnen wie groß denn der
Knopf oben im letzten Loch sein sollte
diese Diskussion führen wir mit ihnen
nicht ganz einfach im
übrigen im übrigen
wir haben wir haben in den letzten zwei
Jahren immer wieder und so gut wie in
jeder Sitzungswoche unsere Vorstellungen
und unsere Änderungsanträge hier im
Deutschen Bundestag eingebracht sie
haben bis zum heutigen Tag
ausnahmslos all samt abgelehnt damit
hier kein Missverständnis entsteht das
ist ihr gutes Recht sie haben hier zur
Zeit die Mehrheit aber bitte ersparen
sie sich und uns doch in Zukunft ihre
Aufrufe zur Zusammenarbeit diese Aufrufe
sind nichts anderes als reine politische
retorik sparen Sie sich und uns die
Zeit und wenn sie es noch etwas genauer
haben wollen da wo wir Sie bitten wie in
der vorletzten Woche geschehen doch
einmal inne zu halten und die Tragweite
ihrer Entscheidungen noch einmal zu
überdenken machen sie von ihrer Mehrheit
hier im Haus kaltschneuzig und
rücksichtslos gebraucht wie z.B beim
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht oder wie wieder
in dieser Woche beim Wahlrecht meine
Damen und Herren und den deutschlandpakt
Migration den haben wir nicht gekündigt
den haben sie
aufgekündigt die
Erfahrungen die Erfahrungen der letzten
Z
Jahre sie wirklichen Zusammenarbeit bis
mit uns nicht wirklich und ernsthaft
interessiert sind im Gegenteil da wo wir
Ihnen wie beim Sondervermögen
Bundeswehr zugestimmt haben halten Sie
sich anschließend nicht an die mit ihnen
verabredeten
Vereinbarungen und
deshalb und deshalb meine Damen und
Herren sind wir auch sehr zurückhaltend
sehr zurückhaltend wenn es um weitere
Änderungen des Grundgesetzes geht ich
stelle Ihnen eine Zustimmung dazu heute
grundsätzlich nicht in Aussicht und ich
schließe eine Zustimmung meiner Fraktion
zu einer Aufweichung der Schuldenbremse
des Grundgesetzes heute von dieser
Stelle aus hier erneut aus damit können
sie nicht
rechenen wir sagen stattdessen unserer
Bevölkerung
die Aufgaben vor denen wir stehen lassen
sich lösen auch ohne zusätzliche Abgaben
und ohne neue
Schuld dazu müssen allerdings die
Prioritäten der Staatsausgaben neu
geordnet werden und meine Damen und
Herren ja ich tue das von dieser Stelle
aus noch vor der Sicherung unseres
Wohlstandes muss die Bewahrung unserer
Freiheit gegen alle Angriffe von innen
und von außen die absolute Priorität hab
nur in Freiheit lässt sich der Friede
sichern nur in Freiheit wird die Ukraine
überleben und nur in Freiheit kommt auch
der Staat Israel hoffentlich eines Tages
wieder zur Ruhe
Freiheit Freiheit und vor allem
Meinungsfreiheit und
Religionsfreiheit sind auch die
Voraussetzungen für den inneren Frieden
in unserem Land dafür gehen die Menschen
in diesen Wochen in vielen hundert städ
zu Tausenden in Deutschland auf die
Straße vor allem um gegen
Rechtsradikalismus und Rechtspopulismus
zu demonstrieren ja dass sie dabei
nervös werden kann ich gut verstehen wir
begrüßen das ausdrücklich wir begrüßen
das
ausdrücklich denn das Treffen der AFD
und anderer Rechtsextremisten in der
Villa Adlon in Potzdam hat offenbar doch
einer größeren Zahl von Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern über den wahren Charakter er
Partei und ihrer Funktionäre die Augen
geöffnet meine Damen und
Herren das
erstarten das Erstarken und das
Anwachsen des Rechtsradikalismus in
Deutschland besorgt uns wie viele andere
hier im Haus und im Land insgesamt
wirklich sehr aber wir sollten weniger
Zeit mit Abscheu und Empörung verbringen
als vielmehr nach den tieferen Gründen
zu suchen warum wir in der Lage sind
denn meine Damen und Herren die
Wählerinnen und Wähler der AFD sind
nicht alle
rechtsradikal aber sie sind alle
ziemlich
frustriert machen wir ein kurzes
Gedankenspiel stellen wir uns doch mal
einen kurzen Augenblick vor wir hätten
in Deutschland eine Regierung die
wenigstens die Ansprüche sind gar nicht
so hoch mittelmäßig gut regieren würde
und die im und die im langjährigen
Mittel in unserer Bevölkerung Hal
undektier W kann sich irgendjemand hier
im Haus vorstellen dass die AFD unter
solchen Umständen innerhalb von 2 Jahren
von 10 auf 20% in Deutschland ange
wachsen wäre meine Damen und Herren das
glauben vermutlich doch noch nicht
einmal sie von den
ampelfraktion die
Lösung die Lösung Problems besteht
offenslich
die unseres Landes lösen dafür sind sie
gewählt und dafür sitzen sie in der
Regierung meine Damen und Herren aber
von einer Lösung der Probleme in
Deutschland sind sie zu Beginn des
Jahres 2024 noch weiter entfernt als zum
Ende des Jahres 2023 vor allem sie
kommen die sie bekommen die
flüchtlingskrise nicht in den Griff
diesetung Schlüsse mit den
Ministerpräsidenten verläuft Z und träge
ich gebe ihn ein Beispiel z.bpel bei der
Einführung der Bezahlkarte meine Damen
und Herren die vor allem die vor allem
an dem systematischen Widerstand von SPD
und Grünen in Deutschland scheiter da wo
sie da wo sie eingeführt wurde da wo sie
eingeführt wurde nämlich in einigen
Landkreisen auf Initiative der dortigen
landtrete sinkt die Zahl der
Asylbewerber über Nacht weil einer der
wesentlichen
aufenthaltsgründe nämlich der Bezug von
Bargeld plötzlich nicht mehr möglich ist
meine Damen und Herren so könnte es in
ganz Deutschland gehen wenn sie sich an
die Verabredungen halten würden die sie
mit dem Ministerpräsidenten des ganzen
Landes mit allen 16 Ministerpräsidenten
geschlossen haben lassen Sie mich in
diesem Zusammenhang zur Klarstellung
aber für unsere Bundestagsfraktion
und auch für die sie beiden tragenden
Parteien hier noch einmal folgendes und
sehr unmissverständlich sagen mit uns
gibt es keine Rückkehr zum Nationalismus
in Europa die Europäische Union hat ihre
Stärken und ihre Schwächen aber sie ist
vor allem die Grundlage für Freiheit
Frieden und Wohlstand auf unserem
Kontinent gerade in Deutschland wir
werden nicht zulassen dass diese
Grundlage zerstört wird meine Damen und
Herren
und wir stehen wir stehen zur
transatlantischen wir stehen zur
transatlantischen Partnerschaft Putins
Russland ist kein Partner für uns
sondern der Feind auch unserer Freiheit
keiner politischen Gruppierung keiner
politischen Gruppierung die diese
fundamentalen Überzeugungen in Frage
stellt werden wir unsere Hand reichen an
diesen Überzeugungen endet jeder meine
Damen und Herren und ein letztes Wort zu
Ihnen meine Damen und Herren von der
sogenannten Alternative für Deutschland
sie haben in den letzten Tagen und
Wochen ihr wahres Gesicht gezeigt sie
machen gezielt und seit langer Zeit
geplant gemeinsame Sache mit mit
Rechtsextremisten jedweder Herkunft ihre
Netzwerke umfassen ihre Netzwerke
umfassen identitäre Bewegungen genauso
wie sogenannte Reichsbürger sogenannte
Reichsbürger meine Damen und Herren
Fremdenfeindlichkeit Antisemitismus und
Nationalismus gehen bei ihnen Hand in
Hand ebenso wie enge Beziehungen zu
Russland und ein tief sitzender
antiamerikanischer Komplex unsere
Botschaft an sie die sie da drüben ganz
recht sitzen ist klar und eindeutig
genug ist genug sie sind sie sind sie
sind nicht die sie sind nicht die
Alternative für Deutschland sie w der
Abstieg für Deutschland und zwar gar
nicht mal nur wirtschaftlich sondern vor
allem moralisch und diesem Abstieg meine
Damen und Herren werden wir uns mit
aller Kraft die uns zur Verfügung stellt
entgegenstellen das Spiel bei ihnen geht
jetzt zu Ende herzlichen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
Friedrich März der Vorsitzende der
Unionsfraktion im Deutschen Bundestag
Parteivorsitzender der CDU am Ende mit
einen mit Worten die ja in die Reihen
der AFD gerichtet hat und davor noch mal
mit einem starken Bekenntnis zu Europa
und mit dem Thema Europa und
insbesondere mit den deutschfanzösischen
mit der deutsch-französischen
Zusammenarbeit hat er seine Rede ja auch
begonnen bevor er dann sehr ausführlich
sich beschäftigt hat mit der
wirtschaftlichen Lage in Deutschland und
welche Mittel und Maßnahmen aus Sicht
der Union jetzt nötig werden